I realize why I don't want to go
why and this is the truth okay be honest
yeah is I'm my comedy is wild for here
yeah I wonder what like even Me farting
here
twice they hated
it she just covered her I mean they're
frightened out of their wits they're on
phone like I don't know where we
are that's my point I I it's like so
what I'm saying is I think I'm way too
much for that but they don't understand
it are you afraid of not being funny
there yes are people not laughing that's
my thing right I don't know how to be
funny in Korea dude no but I think you
know like even though you can't speak
Korean you know enough Korean to be
funny in Korean I feel like you no
there's no way I know six seven words
try your best Korean joke right now our
jokes work in Korea I mean like if I if
I was in if I was on peick and I was
like and I farted like with that I mean
it they would be like what the [__] but
it it would be shocking it would be
shocking yeah it would be shocking but
like in America I've gotten completely
naked and jokes on stage in front of a
packed white room I don't give a [__] I
if I did that there I didn't put me in
cuffs yeah yeah you would get arest I'll
be in North
Korea they would [__] me to North Korea
dude yeah you can't do drugs yeah yeah
no drugs no drug not druged just get
naked I think I if I walk there hey look
at my goto and and i p go M you know I
mean they would be like get get the
cops I don't
understand understand first of all you'd
get arrested here too for that to be
honest get arest no what dud I showed
the
inside the inside of my butthole the
hole open in front of 5,000 people in
Atlanta Georgia I got five I got fine 10
$10,000 wow right but I did it it was
worth every dollar it was worth every
dollar right I you know and then they
were like you can't do that so I made a
a loophole if you come up on stage and
you say a word I'll do it it's like
sometimes it was like you know um Coline
that was one of the words of course so
they're on the stage they Coline I would
drop show my B hole to the person on
stage but I can't do that in
Korea yeah they would they would they it
would be bad yeah but why would you do
you want to do that I want to do here's
here's what you want I'll tell you why
I'll tell you why I'll tell you
why all these social rules that people
[__] have laid down they're just
somebody else's [__] ethics and value
system right what I'm saying is is that
I want to be purely free dude I agree
and I think that's something special
about you see this yeah these are wings
okay I want to fly dude why are crooked
but I know I know I'm going in a
circle flying in a circle dude well like
comedy is your big biggest muscle and
you can't Flex it over there that's your
biggest fear that's what it is well but
but that's the thing it's like if you
haven't tried you don't know yet so oh
that's true that's true but here so try
it out get banned and then but j j j j j
Jay yeah you don't think that we have
algorithms and we know where my podcast
where it does well Australia we're going
there yeah I'm going to kill it there
London I'm going to kill it there we
look at the algorithms in Korea not is
there any percentage in Korea maybe
three
guys those three guys you were talking
about that look like me it's like it's
like me and
like yeah I mean it's Danny CH it's just
too it's too I not say evolved it's just
too much H you'd be surprised I went
there a few months ago a lot of people
tune in Tiger belly I swear to you I
swear you swear I swear I if you if you
booked the venue and probably did a live
podcast for maybe how many people a
thousand people I think you could packet
there's no way you want to bet a
thousand people I swear to you I believe
you I I promise you there's comedy shows
Danny do does not in English not in
English but in Korean but I prom there's
a lot of people who speak English in
Korea too tons maybe at their military
base no no no outside of it too there's
a lot of foreigners there now there's a
lot yeah because because it's right
right now everything is flourishing so
like every single industry is for like
fashion culinary um entertainment like
NTI like and like everything is crazy
out there but you're right though
because if you watch a movie like old
boy yeah mhm you couldn't make that
movie here yeah it's so crazy right a
lot of their movies are so crazy I watch
it and go whoa they're really like you
know I mean they show a lot that's what
I'm saying it's very creative and and
that's why it's like they don't have
that like they didn't have you know a
bazillion dollars to to make a huge
budget movie so it's like like they have
to work with what they had I I feel like
that's what Koreans are really good at
we're making the best like making the
best outcome out of what we have our our
circumstances I feel like we're hella
good at that yeah you are yeah oh
everybody cuz when I did the Wonder
Girls video there was no breaks yeah I
worked for 16 hours work ethic they
don't care about and then and then the
food was a gigantic pot of boiling there
I
am there I am he's right there it
works you having no facial hair is is
crazy it's weird yeah yeah yeah so they
just casted you just to dance around in
there well because he's he's probably
like JP was a fan JP knew I was on Mt TV
here he was aan he's like come on out
and he gave me so much money he gave you
a lot P you a lot to be in it well he go
I go well I go well um how many days of
work one day of work and he goes um I'll
fly you and your friend I I brought my
brother first class they they put us at
the W oh wow still there of course yeah
yeah beautiful at the time yeah and then
um I worked all day though and my
brother was even when he was watching me
work he was going I'm
sorry there's no breaks I'm just
constantly out there Dan yeah yeah it's
insane I think they know the SAG rules
or something are different they don't
way different but that I think that's
how like the the industry and like it
came up so fast and now and now like
we're running [__] BAS yeah while
everyone else was making regulations
Korea was like no we're just going to
work through it I have some other
questions to ask you well you do a
Korean accent uh Korean accent the funny
thing can you do any I've never heard
you do an English Korean act I don't
think I could even do it I I I'd have to
call my mom and be like Mom speaking to
the phone like yeah you do
one oh Bobby oh wait why is why is it I
have to be
oh what is that like oh know right